did you like examine the benefits of
each group it's like oh okay this is
like
[Laughter]
yeah Asian boys has good dental
[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of careful boys today we got someone
really great with us here today we got
Mr Johnny Chang hey
welcome I first came across you
I was doing my little jogs on my
treadmill like this just like that with
his hip sway yeah and I was just looking
and then uh I saw an interview of I saw
your face and then it said um this is
what it said ex-gang member something
like that and I was like what Asian
thugs
see what the [__] that's crazy and it's
after I watched that's when I dm'd you
yeah yeah and you were so friendly oh
yeah yeah I'm super down such a good
interview by the way cool thank you bro
yeah so if in case we we sent it to our
Discord but in case you guys haven't
seen it the software underbelly
interview with with uh Johnny's amazing
uh I I watched that
um like a friend of mine sent it to me
and he was like Hey you have to see this
it was like new and then I I checked it
out and I had to pull over and I I
started crying bro like when you got to
the middle of that talking about your I
don't want to spoil it but just check it
out it's a lot yeah yeah can you give
like can you give like cliff notes of it
because obviously it's your story it's
super good so I don't want to Butch it
or anything but like uh is there a way
you could give like just a short version
of it yeah so basically I just talk
about you know how I grew up I grew up
in the San Gabriel Valley predominantly
like Chinese you know and Mexican area
um I kind of went through a lot of
struggles with like bullying and just
gang banging and you guys are from the
area you know you know it was early late
90s early 2000s was pretty hectic and it
was a tail end of like the gang banging
era but um essentially like I grew up in
that you know I ended up going to Hawaii
which is like you know the worst of the
worst um is that like juvie it's it's no
it's it's like a child's prison
basically oh [__] because people from
Hawaii you can be 10 until 25. oh yeah
but it's like hard crimes like murder
yes yes children that's committed
hardcore so it's like the Harvard but on
the other side it's called Uh Youth
Authority right yeah Youth Authority
Harvard okay congratulations
I'm graduated I graduated but yeah so
from that you know I ended up going to
prison and then after that I came out
and changed my life through like
Ministry basically Christianity what
part of sgv you grew up in Alhambra
Monterey Park area I mean I was all
around I lived in Pomona for a little
bit South San Gabriel uh Almani so but I
was the gang that I was around was in
Monterey Park in Alhambra so was ours
I grew up in Monterey Park too uh um how
old are you 32 33. oh so you would have
been the pee-wees of the generation that
we got I'm 38. oh okay so
um and I grew up in Monterey Park area
too but his face looks so familiar
though it does bro but then I feel like
I was bald headed back then I was too
yeah so wasn't that a prerequisite yeah
no no do you openly talk about the hood
you were from and stuff I mean people
ask where I'm from and you know I let
them know you know it's it's it
literally says watching and the title
I'm from Oceanside watching oh
interesting
damn that's interesting I never talk
about where I was from but I'll tell you
off camera for sure yeah yeah I was just
gonna ask you but that was like yeah
did y'all used to chill with
um Monterey Park a lot uh well back then
we all would function right so it's like
Sunnyside Monte Park Ken side
um they had like age group I mean all
these different they're all fine they're
all from the dub as a true sgv person
because everyone always argues these
things
do you consider Arcadia in the sgv
dang yo to be honest
he's gonna roast all the Santa Anita
homie yeah because if it's Monterey Park
Alhambra maybe even Alhambra like and
north of Maine
come on Arcadia Pasadena Arcadia had I
mean I feel like every city had gangs
right but I remember San Marino and
Arcadia they only had the kids of Mafia
bosses or they had like the United
bamboo guys or like four seasons four
C's or they had Taiwanese watching so
they were like that t-side yeah they
were all like
I don't know what the best way they
weren't gang banging that's the best
place they were hanging around use the
vernacular of dead they were loitering
as long as you make it feel difficult to
say that's good they're soliciting
they they were in groups and they
dressed apart and if you hit them up
they would kind of run away
um so you're saying they're kind of like
they weren't they weren't street thugs
you're also talking about like San
Marino that's like the nicest area
exactly you know what I mean not really
a gangbanger area yeah they were all
sophisticated like they were all
teenagers doing major Deals they got
4.0s man yeah they was they were like
the hustlers they're kind of ahead of
their time like how it is nowadays
everybody's trying to just get money
they were back then we were just killing
each other for a name right so exactly
they were kind of ahead of their time
how did you get like how old are you
when you first joined the gang and how
did you like get into it so I was 12
years old when I first joined and then
three months into it I caught my case so
yeah I was Bang three months and then
yeah how I got in is they call it a put
on you know you get beat up by like
however many people jumped in yeah I get
jumped in and get put on and then from
there you got to put in work after that
did you like examine the benefits of
each group it's like oh okay this is
like four seconds yeah
applying for college
boys has good dental
did you look at all maybe they got a
good dentist inside the you know great
401K yeah I joined more for like
protection I would say because we we
kind of went at it where I lived at was
a lot of Hispanics so I got jumped when
I was like 10 years old and after that
it just changed me bro I was like you
know I'm not gonna never do this again
and then you see back then they had like
the rice rockets and stuff you know the
hackers and whatever and you would see
the homies like they would have like
super baggy jinko or like Anchor Blue
packs solos solos right tubes yeah and
stuff from irvins or whatever and
anyway yeah they they you'd see them and
they have respect and you're like damn I
want to be that and then how I got put
on was they hit me up you know I was
walking on the street little kid yeah
are you banging on me and I was like no
you know I didn't know it was like a
gang of when they pulled the strap and
then one of the dudes and sitting shoddy
was like you want to kick it and I was
like hell yeah so they let me in the car
and then I started going around with
them and then yeah but it wasn't no
sampling no pamphlets here
you should have an older brother or any
older cousins in the same game yeah I
have an older brother in the same game
so the thing about OS is that was it
your brother that hit you up
you know what's crazy is I don't think
we ever ran into each other but we've
heard of each other like I've heard of
you guys yeah
um and I mean your hood was like it was
down but I I never it's so weird because
I feel like I ran into everybody but OS
in real life like at other parties or
whatever everyone says that that's crazy
because we're not that deep you know
we're very very like you know even back
then like we weren't that deep maybe
like 10 people you know that's not a lot
compared to all like your hood had more
people you know so I mean yeah because
it was the main and there was the
hangarounds exactly yeah yeah with us we
we kind of screened a lot of people you
know like we that's better because you
didn't have little [__] like we did
[Laughter]
I went to Hamburg for a little bit I got
kicked out you know I brought a shank to
school or whatever got into a fight and
then I got sent to Century you guys
remember yeah the continuation school oh
my God it's so crazy
the thing is is just bringing back so
much memories like I went to keppel and
I felt like all the dubs at that time
went to Alhambra and all the Asian boys
went to keppel yeah for sure I guarantee
you I know why during that time there
was the Asian and Mexican beef is
because the Asian boys in our high
school had issues with the Lomas and
they started having stuff so they had
they just wanted to [__] up any Asian
kids because they probably thought
you're Asian boys or something yeah
exactly and so I'm thinking you grew up
around the South San Gabriel area yes I
knew it
that's [__] crazy like a historian
dude you got it down to the region
wait until it gets to feudal Japan
you know what mine's got the red and
blue samurai his area is literally like
a three minute drive like a couple like
you could walk yeah to the to the area
that he grew up in from where I grew up
that's not stupid yeah small world you
were just about to mention something
about like having an older brother yeah
so I had so our neighborhood had we're
all family like I think our side has the
most brothers so that's why we we ride
like that because it's you know what I
mean oh yeah it's a personal thing yeah
you're like way tighter yeah how does
your brothers feel about you opening up
and just doing all this stuff they love
it bro oh yeah yeah I mean that's the
one thing like they can't stop like they
can't stop being my my brothers you know
what I'm saying yeah it's like they
might not like it or whatever but the
amazing thing is they actually support
it bro do you think a lot of the all the
your family did all of them kind of turn
around or no I mean there's still people
who are like I'm not gonna say active
but they still have that mentality but I
mean it's it's kind of like we're really
reputable so they just kind of hold on
to that you know what I mean like they
don't change they don't they don't like
change for the better but they don't
also I don't know like continue that
life yeah just like kind of in the
middle they're still down for their
stuff you know what I mean but yeah I
mean I would say I graduated out of it a
lot of my homies were just they're still
like the same mentality but they just
know that they can't really move like
that anymore where it's like somebody
says something go ride on them you know
yeah but they still have it in them like
100 did you have one pivotal moment that
made you go
[__] like what what am I doing with my
life I need to turn it around yeah when
I was locked up
um so when when I went to ya I did four
years maxed out so when I was in there I
think I became a monster bro like there
was too many Mind Games in there you
know I would see kids get raped I would
see kids get stabbed
um you just see a lot of stuff and then
they would steal your stuff and play
games like oh I didn't steal it and it
was just a lot of manipulation so it
kind of fortified like this mindset like
established a mindset of like okay I
need to be like that too or else I'm
gonna get eaten alive I see so you had
to kind of adapt and there was so much
manipulation everyone knows like they
called it throwing [__] like you
literally you just talk [__] and you'll
be like f you and your dad homies like
just out of nowhere like people would
just go just to mess with you yeah and
then you would have to fight the car so
they called it lining it up where you'll
fight one person and then let's say like
you guys are homies right like if I
fight him then I have to fight you and
it's like a one minute break and then
you're home yeah to fight his homie so
it's like it's it's not even really a
riot because riots they just go all out
there was none of that it was like oh
you beat up my friend well I want to
fight you too it was like that you know
so yeah
and then you just keep they call it
Gladiator school because you're
literally fighting I think I fought like
over 40 times for sure
almost every day type of thing it's
almost an everyday thing yeah and then
later you kind of get a little
established but at the end of the day
it's like there's always New Booty new
people coming in trying to prove
themselves you know and I'm so glad that
they closed down a lot of those oh they
shut it down yeah yeah I went to Nellis
Y which is in Whittier
that one was like the craziest one you
know if you ask anybody all the way
babies who know they know like Nellis
why there's yts Nellis there's all these
different ones but now this was like the
most it was terrible bro kids were
getting killed and stuff is that that's
not the one that's not that was on
Whittier Boulevard is it yeah now it's
it's like it's a shopping center
that's so crazy they used to film movies
and stuff there after they shut it down
exactly yeah and then now it's like the
block basically exactly you mentioned so
you went to Hawaii and then you went to
prison after that yeah so I went to ya
uh got out for like 67 days and then you
know committed my second crime
um basically two counts of assault with
deadly weapon there's a shooting a nice
way of saying shooting and yeah that
that I went and got tried as an adult I
went to the big leagues after that how
old were you at the time uh at that time
I was what 16 going on 17. you know they
gave me 10 years but you don't do the
full 10 years it's usually percentages
so
85 yeah I started with Aiden some change
something like that your brother in jail
or yeah my brother was locked up too so
do they put you in the same I never ran
into him oh you know which is great
because my brothers how do you know your
brother did time then
I'm gonna go up to him today bro hey how
did I know
he's like I was there he probably hung
out of here
your Arcadia
were you guys different details all
together yeah yeah my brother went to a
level four so his crime was a little
more crazier he his first him too he his
first offense he caught um I think it
was like 14 years so 14 months yeah
first time getting caught basically and
um yeah they washed them up he was 17
years old as well so he was at I was at
level threes so level three how does
that stuff so level four is like the
maximum security it's the highest you
could go okay and then level three is
kind of like like mid-tier
um it's where all the Knuckleheads kind
of go probably a lot of our homies have
been to level three very few get to
level four like you have to do some kind
of murder or something like that pretty
crazy stuff yeah and then
um level two is just kind of like I
carried a gun you know and and somebody
pulled me over and they gave me 18
months level two Ron plays wrong time
exactly level one is the same thing like
you just drive golf carts and you like
drive people around like it's really
chill in level one but level three yeah
it's pretty cracking level four is
pretty cracking damn yeah and how uh you
said like eight and a half years in
prison there so you said after that in
your very short synopsis uh you found
like Ministry where was that so that was
after after I had gotten out my my mom
she was actually Buddhist like
traditionally being Chinese we were all
kind of raised Buddhists right Asians in
general even if you're Christian there's
a little bit of booty
Christian with incense I know
yeah but I was I was raised um you know
Buddhist and my mom would chat like she
was pretty hardcore she would go and
meet the monks and stuff like that there
was a uh I don't know if it's called the
monastery or whatever it was on Main
Street I don't know if you guys remember
that but it was on Main uh right near
Maine and sixth I don't know it was like
a big thing but anyway she would take us
as kids and she would just pray and
chant and do all these things so in
prison she tried to kind of tell me
about it in the beginning when she would
visit me she'd visit me maybe like once
or twice a month right and she would
talk about like oh you need to you know
do good karma Johnny you know like if
what you put out you're gonna get it you
know get back and
um but I never really listened to her
you know and then all of a sudden like
maybe four or five years before I got
out she started talking about
Christianity and I really didn't like
that I was like Mom that's Hood hopping
right there I'm like what the [__] dude
no loyalty dude oh dude all of a sudden
dude
straight to Christianity why are you
switching
a straight a religion
pick up your mind
yeah so she you know went over to
Christianity and and yeah I just didn't
want to hear it I didn't know anything
about it you know I was just like and
and we had like preachers and chaplains
in prison and they would like be so
condemning like their their actual
prisoners too but they'll be like you
need to stop sinning and we're just like
shut up bro you know what I mean like
you're in here you're you're a lifer
like you did way worse stuff than me and
you're telling me to stop sinning you
know so we just we didn't like that you
know it was a bad stigma and then
also in prison if you if you copper
unlock which means you you unlock to go
to church it's really looked down upon
like you don't you're not down basically
you know because a lot of people when
there's problems like there's a riot
that's gonna happen they'll unlock and
be like I gotta go to church so they can
avoid the right so it's very it's like
bro like you're running away from
service yeah being like a little [__]
or something yeah and you know in prison
is strength in numbers so you have to
you everyone counts especially the the
Asian car like the other car we're very
limited we don't have much people you
know I think the the prisons that I've
been to like been to a few of them like
the most Asians we've ever had on one
yard was like 30 but then that's
compared to 600 Mexicans holy [__] damn
400 blacks you know whatever so yeah we
really had to you know like none of
nobody was Christian in the other car
like there was it was it was bad
when her mom comes to see you like uh
is it do you feel relieved because you
get to finally be with the family member
like what is that do you look forward to
like what's that experience like I'll be
honest the first two years I didn't
um I just ignored her like I know it's
messed up she would drive two hours to
Ironwood State Prison and I wouldn't
come out because I didn't want to face
her yeah so the first two years my mom
you know I'm always sorry about that but
being in there like you you don't want
any you don't you have to like preserve
your mental I heard that from everybody
dude because it makes you soft and then
you feel like you miss her and then like
you can't you gotta be an animal inside
that's for sure yeah people tell you you
just forget about your family like they
straight up say that you know and it's
like damn how do I do that you know but
you'll see people cry and stuff and it's
really like looked down upon
um but yeah she would come for the first
two years and even the CEOs correctional
officers would be like Johnny you're
you're [__] up you know like you
should at least visit your mom because
my mom would come in she's old she's not
knowing how to navigate the prison
system she comes in wrong clothes she
doesn't have a clear bag for her purse
like so she would there's a whole
process she went through a lot and I
didn't help her at all with that nobody
helped her with that right my dad was an
alcoholic he didn't care about that you
know my brother was locked up so no one
could actually help her
she made it you know a point to try and
see her kids obviously but yeah what
what kept her going for two years um she
just kept she told me like by faith you
know she was like you know the she was
like they'll see me sooner or later and
she did that for all your brothers she
had for my brother too did your brother
catch the case the same time or separate
he caught it uh so a year after me for
the same
thing you guys did together or whatever
no no he did it himself he did another
whole separate thing okay he did so he
he went in separately and your mom was
visiting both of y'all going back and
forth damn she was going to Chino and
visiting him and then going to Ironwood
visiting yeah that's rough bro
thank you